I have a routine I come home no later
than 9:30 p.m. most nights I feed my
cats brush my teeth settle in bed read a
book and fall asleep I like routine so
when someone comes up and asked me hey
want to go out tonight my head starts
spinning if we go out at 7:00 the shows
not over till age you wanna have a drink
or two and talks and most likely I'll be
home at 10:15 which puts my bedtime at
midnight it's not that I'm anti-social I
mean bitch we can go out to brunch all
day Earth Day you know what I'm saying
like I wanted to go out and get wasted I
would stay home and get wasted you know
I'm saying it's cheaper it's safer I'm a
good company but at the same time
there's this voice in my head that's
like go out enjoy life what are you 75
god are near death bed are you gonna
think well I'm so glad I stayed at home
all the time
so I listen to this voice and I always
regret it I've been to one concert in my
entire life one it was Santana I know
they're awesome but when I was there I
could not enjoy it I was I just kept
thinking things like oh my god it's so
loud in here you know the entire
Florence sticky little bit boots and of
course there's a line at the bathroom
there's always a line at the bathroom in
these public places my dilemma is always
between going on and trying new things
or having a relaxing night at home and
you know what most times I opted for the
night at home but I don't I don't know I
guess a balance between the two would be
the most ideal but I don't think youth
is meant for me I'm not meant to be a
youth
has actually really afraid that I
wouldn't get this video out on time
because for the past like three or four
days I've been having really weird
abdominal pain my immune system is just
utter crap I'm like always sick or
there's something wrong with my back or
my stomach or like my head I had
migraines what time like I fainted when
me and Ray first started dating I like
fainted and hit my head and he was like
what the hook but yeah like there's just
always something wrong with my body and
I don't
sticks that try so hard to be healthy
but who knows who knows thank you so
much for watching and I hope you check
out the sketch after this and I hope my
stomach is okay
[Music]